what was the hardest part about flying
those routes the hardest part was
getting good marijuana
so the hardest part isn't the flying not
just the flying cars just like driving
your car down
but then i had people that would bring
me on strips that were just
unworthy of an airplane right when the
i'd land on a highway
and uh and this and in the rainy season
i would come back to land again and the
guy wouldn't think about it have like
little hills on both sides and
the wings were out there well the the
grass and the weeds would grow up and it
sounded like
i mean it sounded like tearing the
airplane apart when those wings hit
mowing the grass down both
both shoulders of the airplane the weeds
grew up high in the tropics
so some of that stuff was bad and oh
getting bad gasoline and
telling me that the land here in the
light and and
knock the wheels off when you land oh
you should have landed a little further
up here
you with a ditch down yeah you know that
sort of thing
what was it like landing on a highway
and and when did you have to
land on the highway i landed a highway
most of my life most of the times
in mexico first time i went down there
was a place called pizza lingi
and you had a 900-foot strip and
i would fly down and i'd carry gasoline
wing with me and
uh mari and i would uh go to the grocery
store and buy all kinds of little
goodies and candies and toys
to bring to the children and uh
that sand strip in the in the bend of a
river
was just too short to take off with a
load so there was a young man there
named pedro must not
weighed much over 100 maybe 120 pounds
and he'd get in a
plane with me and he'd direct me 20 30
40 miles away
to a highway and the people walking and
the people would
pull out in a two-ton truck with a
machine gun on it and
a bunch of guys with their arms with
this and they'd block the road and then
another one block it up about a mile
away
and i'd land right over that truck and
they'd load me up it looked like a
bucket brigade when the marijuana come
and i'd shake hands with all of them and
i'd take off right over the other trucks
and sometimes maybe 20 30 40 cars lined
up i
one time i remember a patrol car a
highway patrol car
he didn't have his lights on to go right
over him and then
uh when i started flying to louisiana
the bridge over the mississippi river
there were several contractors that went
broke and that thing was out for years
and about five miles from the river was
flashing red lights
and a detour and then the swamp on both
sides of it in the middle of it were
growing up with 20 feet trees
and that was like an international
runway from anywhere in the world
so i landed on that and over and over
those red lights just like the end of
our runway
and then the next morning we'd go out
there and scrub the marks off the
highway where i'd landed before daylight
wow
you